and welcome everyone today we are going
to be briefly talking about the
symposium that's coming up and where you
will be able to present your posters and
participate in the competition and to
complete your project we will then hear
from dr preetka or who's very
experienced in completing projects and
sharing them in peer-reviewed
publications but before we jump into
that i want to briefly explain
why bioinformatics is such a critical
skill
and what is the gap that we are trying
to address so briefly about us uh we are
uh as a part of a company uh decided
that we want to help others utilize
bioinformatics in an efficient way and
we realized that the gap is actually in
people so when we talk about how data is
generated and how it is used
the
methodologies that have been
so uh tremendously impacted by this
revolution in genomics have made it very
easy to produce cheap and high quality
data that has a lot of detail but the
problem is that there's a gap between
data and information and what that means
is that we are generating data at a much
higher pace than the information that is
reliable clear and actionable
can be extracted from this rmix data and
so when we did a survey a few years ago
not we but actually um people that
rmaseq blog
they found that
the data analysis part
is the highest priority in terms of
filling in that gap so in fact what is
happening is that universities typically
where students get this
really
high quality preparation in many
different fields
do not have the experience in applying
bioinformatics to real research
questions as they graduate and so as a
result when we come to companies that
are hiring the companies are hiring for
hard skills and the universities are
looking for people that have these hard
skills but at the same time they want
people that know how to ask the right
question and find answers in complex
data and so that is why we essentially
designed the onyx logic training
programs to help prepare those kinds of
skills so the real objective here is to
incorporate these different technical
skills into a process of research
and the standard way to start your
research
is to ask a question
asking the right question and finding
the right data that can answer your
question in a comprehensive conclusive
and reproducible way is critical for the
process of believing in science learning
from science being able to find new
insights using the scientific method and
so that is why over the past few years
we have been conducting our research
fellowship programs for students from
around the world that have completed
projects in a variety of different
themes and have presented those at
international conferences however what
we found is that many of the students do
not have the opportunity to complete a
project to a high enough standard to
be able to
present at a
focused topic
so if you have a conference typically
that conference can be about
bioinformatics it could be about
oncology it could be about infectious
diseases and so in those niche topics
there are already experts that kind of
discuss the topic in a very advanced way
and so students don't really have that
many opportunities to have the whole
process guided for them and have the
opportunity to present and get feedback
from high quality
judges from high quality experts
i mean i don't know how many of you have
already been in poster presentations but
so many times you put in so much effort
into your poster you come to a
conference and there's not really a lot
of feedback at least not a lot of
feedback that is constructed that is
addressing the specific question that
you have and so that is really why we
designed this onyx research symposium we
hope that this is going to be an event
that will continue to
that we will continue to use to bring
together experts that understand the
challenges of bioinformatics education
and so what that means is that they
understand how
bioinformatics is changing it's a very
dynamic field because of the new data
types because of the new methods because
of the pandemic because of the people
right there's many factors at play
they also understand that students need
a system they need a system to follow
they need a program that they can
complete and then they need to have an
outcome and that means that they need an
opportunity with jobs with research labs
with a place where they can effectively
apply what they have learned to make a
difference they want to make a
difference in the world using the skills
that they have and so that's why we also
are going to use this as an opportunity
to discuss with universities colleges
high schools how can they utilize
effective resources for training and
education and bioinformatics and because
we have so many participants we're going
to also have some prizes that i will
talk about in just a few moments so what
are we going to cover in this symposium
first of all how can you get noticed in
this community i think that many
students that are learning
bioinformatics or even using
bioinformatics are
not having enough opportunities to
really stand out and what does standing
out really mean that means that you have
the right skills you have something to
show for what you've done and you really
can have a recognition that is certified
from experts from industry leaders that
can say yes this is indeed an
interesting topic you've done a good job
this is what we think about right so
that is what is lacking and we're going
to address that number two we're going
to have an opportunity for you as
students or faculty discuss the
challenges for universities i think
universities are facing a lot of
challenges in placing their graduates in
the right jobs in the right labs helping
them connect the dots a lot of that
process is frustrating to a lot of
people and so that when something is
frustrating we need to address that so
we need to have effective training
effective outcomes and we want to
connect the dots now number three is
where is bioinformatics headed so
bioinformatics is a field that has
undergone a tremendous change in the
past decade
what that means is that what you're
learning today is not what's going to be
needed in the next five or ten years and
so how do you prepare for the future how
do you acquire the skills that are not
just for a technology that is fading
that's going to become irrelevant in
five years but how do you acquire skills
that are really needed and so that's why
we divided this whole symposium into two
parts the first part is going to be on
the changing role of bioinformatics in
research industry and education so we'll
talk about how the pandemic for example
made sharing of omics data and made
analysis of this shared data much more
accessible to a wider range of people
it's not just about bioinformaticians
anymore clinicians people in
biotechnology students citizen
scientists everybody is using
bioinformatics and data analysis to
investigate complex questions like the
question that everybody is thinking
about you know what is the origin of
this pandemic and where is it going how
is it going to continue to evolve and
what can we do about it this has become
from a niche area of research just in a
few labs around the world now a topic
that is widely discussed in the public
media it's on tv it's on the radio it's
in um everywhere we go and so
that means that the role of
bioinformatics in our societies is
changing this is not any more a niche
domain that only a few people they
initiated once the experts can
participate in but also that changes the
role of those experts
how do they
from being experts in one particular
specific type of data or a method become
leaders for a wider community that is
passionate and interested in applying
the same tools to a wide variety of
different challenges right so you all of
a sudden what is the difference between
being a leader and being a researcher
focused on that niche narrow question so
those are all the topics that we're
going to discuss and we're going to
highlight some of these important
techniques technologies and systems that
are being
put together to help address some of
these gaps what are they artificial
intelligence and machine learning
obviously
cheap genomic and all kinds of omics
data
the integration of multi-omics data that
is becoming a pressing need
user-friendly tools for
non-bioinformaticians to get involved
and advanced technologies like quantum
computing for example so those are some
of the things that we will address in
day one
in day two we will talk about how
anyone can get involved and make an
impact so how can you as a student maybe
in high school maybe undergraduate just
learning about biotechnology or maybe
pursuing a medical degree how can you
get involved in the
dry lab and make an impact and how can
you actually contribute to finding
solutions and making progress in these
important topics
so this is uh in day two now in the
conclusion part of it we will introduce
you to some experts who are mentors and
judges and will help us discuss
important topics in both of these
domains
and also provide you with some expert
feedback on some of the top poster
presentations now this is just some of
them but i will later on pass it on to
dr mohit mizunder to introduce a lot of
the other panelists uh towards the end
of today's session but here's what i
would like you to think about as we
prepare for the symposium and as today
we're going to be thinking about how to
make the most out of the post or
presentation session so we will have
questions for the panel that you can now
start thinking about and share with us
so that we can pose these questions to
the experts in the field for those that
are going to come from academia you can
ask questions like what skills are
needed to get hired as a fresher
beginner expert right so you get hired
in industry you get hired in academia
right you want to work in a lab and you
want to understand what kinds of skills
are needed how to ask the right question
how to analyze complex data how to do
data visualization how to work with
others who might not have the same
expertise as you do right these are all
important skills in academia what are
some topics a student needs to learn
about to join research right when you
think i want to become a research and
let's say infectious disease in the
academia what do you need to know to be
able to participate in that kind of
research how to approach a pi to get
into a lab
can undergraduate students join real
research projects right or is this just
for phd students and postdocs so those
are some questions again we're looking
for more questions
please submit those questions in today's
chat we're really looking to you to help
you get those questions answered from
the expert panels now again the same
questions can go for industry right
industry has a different set of needs a
different set of challenges and so it's
good to know what essential skills are
needed to get hired how
can a student
learn about joining industry right it's
very different from academia so how can
what is the path to get there what
positions in industry will see hiring in
the next few years right maybe you're
graduating soon maybe you are graduating
now you want to know in the next five
years how do i get hired how do i know
that i'm going to have a job and how can
students find internships with industry
i think another important topic because
obviously you don't just go from
graduating to all of a sudden having the
right job you want to explore what kind
of positions what kind of skills what
kinds of interesting questions are being
addressed by the industry now we will
also have specific
experts in different domains like
oncology infectious diseases
astrobiology and others and so for those
we also have some specific questions but
we are looking for more
what are some of the hottest trends
where bioinformatics is needed in
oncology i mean we know about
immunotherapy we know about precision
medicine what are some of the other
coming up and hot topics that people
need to think about
should students pursuing medical degrees
learn bioinformatics right so if you are
interested in oncology and precision
medicine perhaps you're looking to
acquire a medical degree i mean should
you even be concerned about
bioinformatics is that going to be a
requirement for the doctors of the 21st
century how can a student work on
clinical data to understand projects
right so in the clinic in the hospital
is a very different setting from when
you take these projects from the public
domain and from research and so what
how can a student really experience that
hands-on without kind of violating the
different rules and regulations around
clinical data and what are some of the
changes taking place in our college
right where is it going how is the
future look and what is the data going
to look like in the next few years so
the same thing about infectious diseases
and we just put together some examples
here obviously we can expand this list
so how has the pandemic change genomics
and infectious diseases right obviously
it has become much cheaper much more
affordable much more easy to acquire and
find public domain data a lot of the
methods for
analyzing the data have become publicly
available as well so how has all how
have all of these trends changed the
area of infectious diseases and then
what is the role of bioinformatics in
public health a lot of students that are
interested in infectious diseases are
interested in public health and
bioinformatics traditionally has not
been part of the public health
curriculum even though biostatistics
obviously has so what is the difference
between
biostatistics bioinformatics and do they
actually talk to each other in some way
and then we will have some hot new
topics i think very interesting
[Music]
developments with astrobiology space
travel living on mars searching for life
right there many interesting topics and
so we hope that we can address some of
those uh questions as well you know how
do you get started i mean do you have to
work for nasa to be able to get started
or can you just start from the comfort
of your own home
finally in all of these topics in
industry in academia in these different
domains we are going to have some prizes
for best posters and presentations so
let me pause right here and let me ask
you how many of you that are here today
with us
are planning to have a poster
presentation
okay so if you do have a poster
presentation please put one
in the chat box
okay so put in number one
all right excellent
okay i'll just give it a couple of
minutes
for all of you to say okay so if you're
planning to have a poster presentation
before we move on i'm going to uh switch
over to my screen over here
and i'm going to ask you to do the
following so this is the link
to the omics logic symposium
okay
if you're going to put number one uh
we're going to okay thank you justly
we're going to be monitoring all of your
answers and we're actually going to be
following up because our objective today
is to help you present and win the prize
right we hope that some of you are going
to win these prizes i'll tell you about
the prizes in just a few moments but i
want to first take a look at this page
again you will see here the registration
form
so you have to submit uh your level of
education where you're from and then
here you have two options listener
registration which is free
or right here poster competition so
poster competition comes with a
registration price i'll talk about that
there are also some waivers for the
price for the the price uh for the
poster but it's important to know that
you have these two options and you have
to submit the right option when you
register for the symposium
after you see all the different speakers
and you have here a complete schedule
for the symposium you will see here some
of the challenges that we're going to be
addressing and right at the bottom you
have an option to submit your research
poster so again right here you can give
a project title and submit a project
abstract
okay this is just your abstract you will
get a review of your abstract and thank
you adjust you for posting the complete
form so the complete form um inclu yeah
is separately available as well
but what is important is that right when
you submit you will get some feedback
from our team who's going to review all
of the abstracts and we'll give you some
feedback whether your poster
qualifies for the competition and for
the poster presentation
and some pointers to address some topics
to address before you actually submit
the full thing okay so important there's
a process first you register you submit
you get feedback address that feedback
okay very important the deadline is
going to be on monday next monday so you
still have all of your weekends that's
coming up so today is wednesday so you
almost have uh four or five days to
complete that and today um in the next
few hours we're going to be
yes there's going to be an attendance
certificate for the symposium for both
of the days uh there's going to be some
additional workshop opportunities before
and after the symposium
um okay great so that is about the
submission process
now for those of you that are actually
going to be interested
in participating
you can check please because i know that
people are from different countries
please check the schedule okay so here
we have the schedule maybe or just you
can paste the link for that as well
the schedule will start very early u.s
time to accommodate some of the
international participants we have
excellent speakers in all of the
sessions
some of them are still being finalized
but you will find here all of the
information about the speakers some
amazing experts with very important
topics in the domain in bioinformatics
and you will see some
breakout sessions and so when you're
thinking about the symposium please plan
out to be there to be on time
to make sure that you have registered
for the appropriate session and to make
sure that you have added
or just me please paste the link
to the schedule here
okay so if you can
make sure that you're there you you have
registered correctly
for
the type of breakout session and so
please make sure that marketing at pine
bio and marketing at omixlogic.com
are in your contact list so that you're
getting the notifications we're going to
be sending all of this information by
email to those of you that have
registered again if you just want to be
a listener it is free for those of you
that want to submit a poster and
participate in the competition there's a
very modest registration fee this is for
us to help with covering the costs of
the symposium and we want to make sure
that you have the right information now
some of you um
yes so anushka we will send out
follow-up emails
uh and the emails are going to be coming
from on marketing and pine bio and
marketing and omix logic so it's very
important to keep those in your
um in your contact list
okay so where is this going why
symposium why the posters are just going
to be a one-time event or can you do
more with your project so we recommend
for all of you that are planning to
present to actually follow a very
defined process that we've defined on
the omics logic learn portal you can
essentially do all of the steps as a
participant of our research fellowship
program i know that not all of you are
participants so this is something that
you can consider in the future because
to make a lasting uh
lasting impact from your project you
don't want that project to just go away
and there's a way to submit a project
i'm sure that dr harpreet will speak
about this and have this featured on our
portal so that industry and academia and
people in our network are aware of you
and aware of your project and so you can
see right here some of the
some of the examples of projects that
are going to be a part of the
competition
pragati i see that you've raised your
hand if you could hold off just a couple
more minutes
and if you have a question you can put
that in chat and our team will answer
that okay so that is another link so if
you want to kind of go for this longer
term we have some opportunities for you
there but also
just briefly i want to show you where
you can complete the registration for
the full symposium and the poster
presentation okay so uh here we have a
program
called onyx research symposium
you will find your information being
filled out um for you know the next few
days until the end of this week and
you'll see how we have some options for
you to get registered for the
competition
okay so just keep that in mind
okay so now i want to briefly tell you
about
the uh prizes right how do you what what
are you going to be competing against
what are some of the criteria what are
some of the things that the judges are
going to be looking for
so as you know your poster is going to
have several different sections it's
going to have an introduction um methods
and results and discussion or conclusion
so for each one of those there's going
to be a point system to get
feedback and so this feedback is going
to come with some additional notes
um so first of all
uh we're going to uh look at the
introduction right the introduction will
be uh graded by having great exciting
ideas strong rationale great hypothesis
right so refining your question is a
very critical part of making an
impactful project
number two
you will have methods and results so
we're looking for
a very clear interpretation visually
clear logically connected
important findings innovative techniques
and strong statistics so it needs to
have significance right it has to have
significance and it has to have uh
strong results
and then number three discussion
conclusion you need to have
something that leads to a need of
further research we're sure that these
posters are going to be great but
typically a poster is a beginning of a
project not the end of the project so in
your objective of getting to this part
you actually want to be able to
get feedback from experts so that you
can take your research further and
eventually publish right in publication
with peer review that's really where you
want to be
but in this opportunity you want to get
feedback to refine all of this so
don't worry about winning the prize
necessarily even if you won't win the
prize you will get feedback about how
you can go further with this project and
then finally presentation quality so it
not only has to be scientifically sound
but it's very important to make it look
nice to make it presentable to make it
clear to make your graphics clear and so
that is what we will talk about in the
last in the next few minutes
again register to participate
make sure that you're applying for a
poster competition we will have prizes
uh and
uh we will have a best high